Professor Wireless.
Sandy's is a professor of criminal
justice at the Indiana University in
Bloomington,
Indiana for a number of years now.
She's worked as a part of the
capitol jury project and professors.
Sandy's thank you so much for joining us.
And could I ask you to start by just
telling us what the Capitol jury project
has been doing and how
long it's been doing it?
Sure.
Um,
thank you for inviting me.
I'm,
I've been a part of the capitol jury
project since it started in 1991.
Um,
it began with funding from the National
Science Foundation at that time,
um,
and it has continued to receive funding
from the National Science Foundation
over and three separate occasions.
Uh,
the project began with 14 separate states
being involved in that first phase of
the project.
Um,
and it involved having professors of
both law and social science across the
countries working together with a core
set of questions that we interview,
uh,
face to face interviews
with capitol jurors and the,
the interviews chronicle the jurors entire
experience with they're having served
on a capital case.
So from the very first time that they
may have heard about the crime to when
they were selected for a jury,
how they were selected for
the jury to the guilt phase,
the guilt deliberations,
penalty phase,
penalty deliberations,
and even after the trial,
any,
you know,
experiences that they had.
And today in that phase,
we've now had interviews with
1,198 or across the country.
Um,
um,
these interviews,
as I said,
our face to face interviews and they
take on average about three and a half to
four hours to complete.
And do you interview jurors who have said
on both cases where the death penalty
was imposed as well as swim
life imprisonment was imposed?
Yes.
As part of our sampling protocol
in each one of the jurisdictions,
we,
uh,
selected samples specifically
trying to get equal numbers.
Sometimes it's a little bit easier to
get one type of case versus the other,
but for the most part we ended up with
right around 55% who had served on death
penalty cases and 45% would
serve down life cases.
And you and your colleagues
who are academics throughout.
And as you said,
lawyers,
law professors throughout the country
have published a number of articles,
uh,
on what your findings,
so Ben from,
from these interviews,
is that correct?
That is correct.
I think there's,
you know,
some 50 odd articles,
uh,
probably close to a dozen
dissertations at this point.
So it's been an ongoing
program of research.
Yes.
Could you tell us,
I mean,
if you've done any research on when
jurors start making up their mind about
punishment and capital cases?
Okay,
sure.
That was one of the very first
articles that colleagues,
and I should know that the principal
investigator on the project is Professor
William Bowers.
And one of the first
articles that he and I,
and I believe it was Ben Steiner,
Larry Steiner road,
was looking at foreclosed and partiality.
And it really became evident to us,
um,
that the jurors were really making their
decisions very early on in the case.
And,
and what I mean by that is that we ask
that your ears at the end of the penalty
phase at the,
excuse me,
by the end,
at the end of the guilt phase,
before you started the penalty phase,
did you then think that the defendant
should be given a sentence of death?
Do you think they should be given a
sentence of life or were you uncertain?
And as you can see in the first slide,
what we found is that basically 50% of
the jurors remained undecided as to what
they believe the appropriate penalty
should be at that particular time.
And additional
approximately 30% said that,
um,
death was the appropriate
penalty at that time.
And an additional 20% said that they
believe that life was the appropriate
penalty at that time.
And so what that really said to us was
that even though we have this bifurcation
of proceedings where the
guild and penalty phases,
they're supposed to be separate,
um,
while they may be separate physically,
psychologically,
that's not always the case.
And that jurors are really
talking about thinking about,
um,
the penalty long before the
penalty phase of the trial
and of course contrary to the instructions
so that they receive from the judge,
which is not to make up their mind
about punishment until after the penalty
phase and even then not to make up their
mind until after the closing arguments
and the instruction of the court.
But you're finding that
much earlier in the process.
Jurists are,
are reaching tentative conclusions
about the sentence in the case.
Definitely.
And I think part of that comes in because
of the jury selection process as well.
Um,
jurors are being asked very early on
obviously about their views on the death
penalty and the extent to
which they could vote for it.
And so to all of a sudden come in and
start with issues related to the death
penalty and then stop and say,
okay,
now you can't really consider it.
Um,
Eh,
during the guilt phase
is really difficult.
Um,
these are people obviously who for the
most part are not trained in the law.
Um,
they don't necessarily understand the,
you know,
the differences,
the slight little differences of what
may be required at different times of the
trial and to all of sudden ask for
where they stand on the death and their
ability to vote or to ability to
consider the penalty and then say it's
irrelevant I think is a little difficult.
When you hear,
you know,
the evidence presented in the guilt phase,
have you found anything about people's
preferences for the duff going into death
penalty trials?
Um,
well one of the things that
we asked all of these jurors,
um,
was a specific question asking whether
they thought that the death penalty was
the only acceptable punishment,
uh,
whether they saw thought it was an
acceptable punishment or unacceptable as a
punishment for a variety of
different kinds of murders.
It might be death eligible.
And what you can see here
in the next slide is,
um,
we asked specifically,
what percent of these jurors indicated
that they thought that death would be the
only acceptable punishment.
And for the one question about murder by
someone previously convicted of murder,
you can see that it's almost
72% of these jurors said,
and these are jurors who had served.
So they'd been found qualified
to serve on a death penalty case.
Almost 72% of them said that they thought
that death was the only acceptable
punishment for a person.
Um,
previously convicted of murder.
Similarly,
57% thought that death was the only
acceptable punishment for a planned
premeditated murder and the like.
And so for many of these jurors,
um,
what you're seeing is that death is
seen as really the only acceptable
punishment for several of the kinds of
crimes that are death eligible and end up
being these capital cases.
And these are jurors who said,
who actually served.
So the jury selection process did not
identify these people as being biased in
favor of the death pump,
even though they clearly were.
Yes.
I mean,
these were all jurors who had
actually served on capital cases.
They clearly had made it
through the death qualification,
life qualification process.
Um,
one of the things that we've done also
is to look a little bit more at some of
the,
the questioning of
jurors in capital cases.
And this has been done more recently
focus primarily actually in Kentucky.
Um,
where we did a slight little variation
where we asked an additional question
trying to look at the Morgan type question
and whether somebody could consider a
sentence of life.
Let me just interrupt
you there for a second.
For the four,
are those watching and Morgan,
you mean Morgan Versus Illinois?
The case that said a person could be
disqualified if they felt so strongly in
favor of the death penalty
that they couldn't fairly
consider life imprisonment.
Correct.
That that's Morgan.
I was referring to.
Thank you.
And um,
when we asked the jurors that one of the
things that we did in Kentucky was to
look at their responses to
that kind of general question.
And then what we did was to
compare it to the actual,
they're descriptions of how
they made their decisions.
And what you find is that there's a
disconnect that you're sometimes believe
that they could be fair.
You know,
it could be fair,
they could be impartial,
they would not be,
you know,
they would not necessarily
just vote for death.
At least that's how they
see it at the outset.
And yet part of it is once they are
exposed to some of the facts of the cases,
what you find is that they are incapable
of considering anything other than a
sentence of death.
And so we're looking at these
differences in terms of at the outset,
these traditional automatic
death penalty voters,
people who juring jury selection.
You could ask and somebody could consider
and they could think about it and be
very honest and sincere
in their responses.
But to the extent that attorneys are not
allowed to ask pretty expansive kinds
of questions,
jurors aren't necessarily don't know what
kinds of situations they may be faced
with.
And so they can say very honestly,
during jury selection,
of course I could consider a
variety of different penalties.
And yet when they are exposed to the
particulars of the facts of these capital
cases,
they realize that death might be the
only acceptable punishment that they can
see.
Let me ask you this.
Have you looked into jury instructions?
Lawyers think jury
instructions are important,
but one sitting in a courtroom kind of
wonders if anybody understands the jury
instructions.
Uh,
have you looked into that?
That is one of the other areas that we've
addressed as part of the Capitol jury
project.
And one of the professors who was
involved in the initial phases of the jury
project was,
um,
and then by the name of
Professor James Logan Buell,
who had done some work in North Carolina,
um,
looking at instructions in capital cases.
And so we ended up adopting
some of his questions,
which was really basically looking at how
jurors understand whether they have to
be unanimous on mitigation and the like.
Um,
and as you can see in this next slide,
um,
what we have here is that,
uh,
almost,
you know,
45%,
44.6% of the jurors fail to understand
that they can consider anything in
mitigation.
And this is going to the
average across all states.
A 66.5% did not know that they did not
have to be unanimous on mitigation.
Um,
let me just back up there and just say,
the Supreme Court has held that
jurors do not have to be unanimous on
mitigation,
that any juror can say,
I think it's a mitigating factor even
though the other 11 or two can say that.
And the other 10,
uh,
each juror makes an individual decision
and do not have to be unanimous on
mitigation.
You're telling me that
jurors don't understand that?
Definitely not.
We had almost two thirds of
the jurors indicated as much.
Um,
we also had almost a half,
49% of the jurors said that they did not
know that mitigations did not need to
be found beyond reasonable doubt.
They come in and believe in
that that's the standard.
Um,
and less,
but still almost a third were unaware
of the fact that aggravators had to be
proved beyond a reasonable doubt.
And so there's a pretty consistent
pattern here of jurors not being able to
understand the instructions.
But there's,
there's also been a lot of additional
research outside of the Capitol Jury
Project that I think speaks
to this issue as well,
which is,
you know,
research done.
A lot of it has been done on college
campuses and looking at ways in which you
might be able to increase comprehension.
It's one thing to say that jurors
don't understand the instructions.
It's another thing to say,
well,
is it possible to improve the
comprehension of the instructions?
And there've been two sort of different
types of programs of research done in
this area.
One is,
uh,
working with linguists,
so having lawyers and
judges and everybody,
you know,
all parties involved work with a linguist
and other social scientists to try to
rework the instructions in a way that
obviously is keeping to the legal
requirements,
but also making them more understandable.
And what you can find under those
circumstances is you can't improve the
comprehension.
Um,
there are studies that have found
comprehension improved up to,
you know,
70 some I think there was one that
was over 90% of comprehension.
So,
so that is possible.
There's also been another
avenue of research.
Um,
that has done the same
thing in some respect,
but instead of just asking
these kinds of questions,
which I think are really important
and indicative of comprehension,
this other avenue has
presented people with,
um,
these vignettes.
So instead of just saying,
can they sort of understand
the particular instruction,
are they applying it correctly?
So for example,
you could give a vignette of,
you know,
two to three sentences of a jury.
Um,
is dis,
you know,
was discussing mitigation.
One of the jurors believes that the
person's history of child abuse was a
mitigator.
The 11 other jurors do
not agree with that.
They therefore do not discuss,
uh,
the defendant's child abuse has,
has the jury operated in
accordance with the law.
So it's a way to test
not just comprehension,
but the application,
which really is what's
critical here as well.
So we may be putting a
little more trust in juries,
uh,
then perhaps we should,
in terms of how well they understand,
uh,
what's going on in terms of the
biases they bring into the process.
Um,
is that what you're finding?
You know,
I,
I'm a firm believer in,
I think that jurors do
the best that they can,
but I think there's a lot more that
the courts could do to help them.
Um,
I think that by not explaining the
instructions or perhaps not writing the
instructions in a way that's
really conducive to two jurors,
I think is really doing a disservice.
I think.
I think there are steps
that could be taken,
um,
that would help the process.
So I think jurors like anybody who's
going to come in with certain biases.
Um,
and I think the benefit or the potential
benefit is to be able to explain to
them how those biases operating to sort
of help them and be able to determine,
allow the attorneys to determine whether
there's such expansive kinds of biases
that this would really impact
the fairness of the trial.
Or is it through the process
of instructions where you
could try to guide the
jurors in ways that they can
really understand what is
being asked of them under
these circumstances.
And do you have any sense of the extent
to which courts are trying to do that?
I mean our summon a state trying to do
it or other national efforts to try to
make jury instructions easier to
understand and to apply or do you know,
you know,
you hear periodically of different
jurisdictions where they have really
attempted to improve the instructions.
Um,
I think,
um,
I I know that here in Indiana there,
you know,
have tried to improve instructions.
I know in other jurisdictions,
I know more recently,
um,
I believe it's in Massachusetts,
they've really looked
at eyewitness testimony,
obviously not capital cases,
but the different
jurisdictions have really,
you know,
our,
our beginning,
they've done understood I
think for quite some time,
but there's some jurisdictions and some
judges I would say who are more likely
to take the lead.
Um,
there's the center for jury studies that
has been doing a little bit of work in
this area as well.
Um,
and I,
so I don't know of one state
where I could say to you,
you know,
this is a state that has really done
a lot to improve their instructions.
Um,
I think where,
and I've heard of
instructions being changed.
Oftentimes,
I don't know that there are these kinds
of studies that I'm talking about that
occur at the outset.
I think what ends up happening is that
they go in and the committees will revise
the instructions and you know,
they'll probably be improved.
Um,
but then you'll have a social scientists
going after and test it and say,
well,
wait a second.
You know,
your comprehension may have
improved from 40% to 60%.
Um,
is that enough?
Are there ways that we could
have improved it even more?
So?
I'm not familiar.
There may be,
but I'm not familiar with jurisdictions
that have really adopted that kind of
model.
So what do we know for sure is that this
is certainly something that needs to be
done.
If jurors are going to be able to do
their job the way they're supposed to.
I believe that.
Yes.
And you know,
one of the things that I,
I've looked at independent of these
kinds of studies that I've just talked
about,
is trying to,
why is it that the jurors do
not understand the instructions?
Um,
I can tell you that anytime
I've read an instruction,
I'm confused.
I inevitably call a lawyer and say,
what exactly do they mean by this?
There are many different ways in which
the instructions could be misinterpreted.
And so one of the things that I did
just one day decided I would just run
through the instructions.
Um,
I was giving a talk in Kentucky and
decided that I would run the instructions
through word and see what word would tell
us was the comprehension level and the
level of understanding for that.
And if you've ever written an article or
you know any kind of paper and word you
can ask it to just tell
you what the level is,
the grade level of the,
the document.
Um,
as anybody on a university campus,
when you submit materials
for conducting research,
oftentimes when they're being reviewed,
they say you should,
you know,
be writing them at a certain grade level.
And so I decided to sort
of throw those through a,
read them through word.
Um,
and you can see on this next slide that
I just took the actual quotes from word.
When they say this,
these are the tests that they run
and they have the flesh reading ease,
which you know,
goes from zero to 100.
It's a hundred point scale and they,
their target,
there's from 60 to 70,
and then they have the grade level index,
which is just our standard grade level.
You know,
if you,
and they say we recommend that you should
be writing your document documents at
a seventh to eighth grade level.
And so when I ran some of
these instructions through
from Kentucky and all I did
was take their pattern instructions,
um,
and I,
I tried to make them
as simple as possible.
So I only had one,
let's say aggravating circumstance,
one mitigating circumstance and tried
to make them pretty straight forward.
Um,
whichever ones they were listed,
but just try to make it pretty direct.
Um,
and you'll see here the first,
um,
even so says instruction too,
but here's one that's looking
at mitigating circumstances.
And when I read,
you know,
conducted the head were run
the readability statistics.
You can see that the flesh reading e so
that's the one from the scale from you
know,
a hundred point scale that was
at 42 that's supposed to be,
they suggest words as it should be
between 60 and 70 and the grade level was
14.2 so you're talking about at least a
sophomore level of college that you're
expecting for your jurors.
When you look at
aggravating circumstances,
the ease level goes down a little 30.8
but the grade level also goes down a
little.
So it's more difficult to re to re.
Um,
but it's also a little
bit more understanding,
greater understanding of the grade level.
Only need a high school education,
but it's that last one that gets me
in Kentucky where you'd look at your
authorized sentences.
Um,
and again,
this is just the pattern
and the test results.
They're reading it ease is
15.7 on a hundred point scale.
That's supposed to be between 60 and 70.
And the grade level is 23.8.
And so it's beyond college.
It's a beyond a phd.
It's a phd and a JD.
I mean it's,
it's a really,
as you might imagine,
a really high threshold to expect jurors
to be able to understand what's being
asked of them.
And so to me it's no great surprise that
they may revert back to what they think
is the right way,
but what they think oftentimes may not be,
especially when we are talking
about issues related to mitigation,
because I think what happens is jurors
come into court with this understanding
of your,
you have 12 jurors.
It has to be proof beyond a reasonable
doubt and everybody has to agree,
well that may be true
for your standard case.
It may be true for the guilt phase,
it may be true for your aggravators,
but it's not true for your mitigators.
And so if jurors don't understand that
and they're not told that in a way that
they can understand it,
they may be dismissing very compelling
mitigation because they think they cannot
really consider it.
Sandy,
this is a fascinating information.
It gives us an awful lot to think
about and I am most grateful to you for
sharing your knowledge and
your time with us here.
It's been my pleasure.
Thank you very much.